قَالَ الأَرْنَبُ مَامَا مَامَا *** اسْمَحِي لِي أَنْ أَخْرُجْ
أَمْضَيْتُ وَحْدِيْ أَيَّامًا *** بِالمَنْزِلِ هَذَا مُزْعِجْ
قَالَتْ لاَلاَ يَا أَرْنُوبْ *** أَخْشَى يُؤْذِيَكَ الثَّعْلبْ
أَنْتَ صَغِيرٌ يَا حَبُّوبْ *** وَالمَاكرُ جِداً مُرْعِبْ
غَافَلَ مَامَا وَتَسَلَّلْ ***  لِلخَارِجِ دُونَ اسْتِئْذَانْ
يَجْرِي يَمْرَحُ لاَ يَخْجَلْ ***  وَحْدَهُ فِى كُلِ البُسْتَانْ
شَاهَدَهُ الثَّعْلَبُ ثَعْلُوبْ ***  فَرِحَ وَهَلَّل واسْتَبْشَرْ
قَالَ سَآَكُلُ ذَا الأَرْنُوبْ ***  يَبْدُو وَحِيداً يَتَبَخْتَرْ
هَاجَمَهُ بَغْتَةْ الثَّعْلَبْ  ***  فَمُهُ للآَخِرِ مَفْتُوحْ
وَجَرَى الأَرْنَبُ كَيْ يِهْرُبْ  ***  وَبِإِحْدَىْ قَدَمَيْهِ جُرُوحْ
اخْتَبَأَ بِجِذْعِ الشَّجَرَةْ ***  يَبْكِى وَيَنْدُبُ أَفْعَالَهْ
وَتَقَصَّى الثعلبُ أَثَرَهْ ***  فَشِلَ وَضَيَّعَ آَمَالَهْ
عَادَ الأَرْنبُ لِلمَنْزِلْ ***  قَبَّلَ مَامَا مُعْتَذِرًا
وَالدَّمْعُ غَزِيرًا يَنْزِلْ ***  مِنْ عَيْنَيْهِ مُنْحَدِرًا
قَالَتْ مَامَا يَا أَرْنُوبْ ***   اسْمَعْ نُصْحِى وَسَتَسْلَمْ
مَامَا وَبَابَا يَا مَحْبُوبْ ***   بِالصَّالِحِ أَدْرَى أَعْلَمْ